manquerait pas ce sommet du football
d'antenne 2 va diffuser dans 25 minutes
environ
la finale de la coupe du monde entre
l'argentine et les pays-bas
thierry van lent et bernard père vous
êtes déjà dans les tribunes du stade de
river plate où la fête doit déjà avoir
commencé
eh bien oui le stade de river plate est
archi comble tout de bleu ciel et blanc
vêtu par une journée grise à buenos
aires on attend la finale et on attend
aussi la consécration de cette équipe de
l'argentine l'une des rares formations
offensives de championnat du monde qui
aura évidemment forte à faire face au
représentant du vieux continent les pays
bas en finale il ya quatre ans
et regardez écoutez tête en bien
le match commencera très exactement dans
30 minutes 10
et on s'attend à une grande finale qui
pourrait peut-être à elles seules sauver
un championnat du monde qui n'a pas été
historique
bien oui quand déboule en 30 minutes
oui thierry rolland rendez-vous dans 30
minutes donc c'est le général videla que
l'on vient de voir dans les tribunes du
stade de river plate le chef de la junte
militaire le président de la république
argentine qui remettra la coupe au
vainqueur de cette finale
cela n'a pas modifier l'évolution mon
pays at il dit hier soir mais cela au
moins modifié pendant un temps le
comportement des argentins paul lefèvre
non nous envoyés spéciaux sur place en
argentine a pu s'en rendre compte
la coupe du monde a été pour un la
première occasion depuis bien longtemps
de descendre dans la rue et d'y rester
sans qu'une bombe ou une rafle de police
viennent met un point d'orgue au chant
de la foule l'argentin redécouvre donc
le plaisir de crier de danser ensemble
dans la rue c'est une sorte de carnaval
improvisé qui a pour inconvénient majeur
de doute ne vire éveillé jusqu'à 3 ou 4
heures du matin mais c'est aussi la
raison le symbole il faut le dire de la
popularité entre guinée du général
videla
c'est un fait l'homme de la rue est plus
sensible actuellement à ce climat de
tranquillité dans la vie quotidienne
qu'à la restriction de certains droits
civiques
ce qui ne veut pas dire que parmi les
rires et les danses hier soir il n'y
avait pas des cris qui réclamaient des
élections et en santé comme une sorte
d'accord tacite entre le pouvoir et la
foule la meilleure preuve en est sans
doute l'extrême discrétion d'une police
pourtant on y présente
l'accord en somme est le suivant pour le
gouvernement cette fête publique est la
preuve qu'il a réussi à remettre l'ordre
et qu'il est sûr du calme de la foule
pour l'homme de la rue
ce sont les retrouvailles d'une certaine
liberté à savoir qu'elle entend d'ici le
mondial est une étape ou simplement une
parenthèse pour en terminer avec cette
page sportive je vous rappelle que
quatre jours du départ du tour de france
bernard hinault qui est devenu cet après
midi à sarrebourg champion de france
cycliste professionnel plus qu'un
athlète isme l'équipe de grande bretagne
largement battu la france par 167 points
et demi à 130 deux points et demi
l'actualité politique maintenant avec
tout d'abord les déclarations de jacques
chirac le président du rpr a nancy il
participait à une journée régionale du
rpr et au club de la presse d'europe 1
jacques chirac s'est de nouveau
prononcée contre une plutôt pour une
roland
économique planifié il ne suffit pas de
laisser faire la liberté et la
concurrence pour que tout s'arrange
il faut une impulsion il faut encore des
interventions de l'état sinon c'est
accepter que les travailleurs fassent
les frais de l'opération
notre conception nous différencie de la
thèse actuellement retenu par le
gouvernement a dit jacques chirac le
président du rpr a également exprimé son
désaccord sur les élections à la
proportionnelle
même pour les municipales comme l'avait
souhaité le chef de l'état lors de sa
dernière réunion de presse nous avons
dit à maintes reprises alors que ici ou
là quoi dans les rangs de la majorité et
chez nos partenaires
ceux ci étaient contestées nous avons
dit que nous étions profondément
attachés à notre système institutionnel
tel qu'il est défini par la constitution
de 1958 et que nous n'accepterions
jamais qu'elle soit remise en cause et
ses pourboires
nous n'accepterons jamais la remise en
cause de ces institutions ni d'ailleurs
de tout ce qui conditionne mon pour les
institutions et c'est dans cet esprit
que nous avons dit très clairement que
nous n'accepterions jamais encore que
nous n'ayons aucun intérêt électoral
la remise en cause de la loi électorale
législative et c'est dans le même esprit
pour les mêmes raisons que nous avons
dit que nous le pouvions accepter la
remise en cause de la noise municipales
telles que chef de l'état vient de nous
la proposer d'abord parce que cela
représente un défi à la nécessaire
autorités de ceux qui doivent assumer la
responsabilité des communes et c'est
ensuite un premier pas fait dans une
direction que nous contestons et qui est
celle du laxisme et vu compromis parmi
les événements politiques de la semaine
à venir notait bien sur votre agenda de
télévision mercredi soir antenne 2
cartes sur table exceptionnel interrogé
par jean-pierre elkabbach et alain
duhamel
madame jeannette thorez vermeersch une
des figures du parti communiste qui a
décidé de parler après des années de
silence en 1968 après l'entrée des chars
à prague
elle avait quitté la direction du parti
communiste tout en restant membre du
parti mercredi soir dans cartes sur
table elle répondra aux questions de
jean pierre elkabbach et d'alain duhamel
un témoignage important au moment où un
large débat se développe à l'intérieur
du parti communiste autre débat ce qui
se déroule en ce moment au sein du parti
socialiste
le crs l'ailé gauche du parti socialiste
organisait durant ce week-end à evry son
douzième colloque
il s'agissait pour les militants du crs
de faire le point de réfléchir sur ce
qui se passe actuellement au sein de
leur parti ils ont voulu avant tout
définir une ligne politique
une stratégie daniel grandclément a
insisté pour nous à ce colloque du crs
le crs se trouve devant trois problèmes
le premier c'est de maintenir sa
cohésion de fer que ses militants de se
dilue pas entre partisans par exemple de
michel rocard août françois mitterrand
est donc de garder son identité
le deuxième c'est le garder le même
impact sur l'ensemble du parti savait qu
à epinay en 1971 c'est un petit peu les
idées des dirigeants du crs qui avait
ancré le parti à gauche
aujourd'hui il voudrait garder le même
pouvoir de décision sur l'ensemble du
parti
le troisième enfin c'est que comme
toutes les autres composantes du parti
socialiste vient crs a subi l'échec des
législatives de plein fouet
aujourd'hui se reposent encore une fois
le problème de l'union de la gauche de
l'union étaient communes bien sûr
aujourd'hui les conditions ne sont pas
réunies d'une reprise de l'union de la
gauche mais nous estimons qu'à travers
les luttes la construction du parti ceci
ce doit se faire doit s'effectuer et que
dans le même mouvement les socialistes
et les communistes qui sont confrontés
au même problème
et bien puisse mobiliser entraîné avec
eux toutes celles et tous ceux qui
veulent vraiment le changement est ce
que croyez vous avez toujours autant d'
influence au sein du parti socialiste
que vous en aviez avant les élections
bien écouter le parti socialiste
aujourd'hui est en pleine recomposition
et à partir de ce moment là il est
difficile de voir quelle est la force
que peut représenter le crs mais le crs
et un pôle idéologique et nous sommes
convaincus qu à travers la préparation
de ce colloque cette discussion
approfondie et bien nous pourrons
effectuer exercer une influence très
forte
c'est d'ailleurs ce que nous recherchons
et dans le cadre de la préparation du
projet socialiste est dans le cadre de
la préparation du congrès on veut être
en france aujourd'hui pour le premier
tour d'élections municipales au creusot
et pour le deuxième tour à aix en
provence à flers et à briançon
à retenir aussi chez dans l'actualité
politique de ce dimanche que le parti
socialiste démocrate kerry hintermann
s'est finalement déclarée favorable à
une alliance avec l'udf l'union pour la
démocratie française dont les statuts
ont été publiés officiellement ce matin
par le journal dit maintenant au journal
officiel
dans le domaine social suite de trois
conflits boussac toujours des barrages
sur la route nationale 57 aujourd'hui
barrages dressés par des ouvriers des
usines textiles moulinex la cfdt
majoritaire appelle les grévistes à
poursuivre l'occupation et renault la
direction a donc décidé l'arrêt du
chômage technique qui frappait près de
9000 ouvriers mardi prochain
réunis à paris ce week-end les assises
du judaïsme français thème retenu pour
cette année pour ces assises
l'accueil c'est à dire l'examen des
problèmes matériels et religieux que
pose l'intégration de nouveaux venus par
des communautés déjà existantes
accueillir les nouveaux venus faciliter
leur intégration sans nuire à leur
diversité
plus qu'un thème de réflexion pour la
communauté juive française mosaïque
changeantes se retrouve aujourd'hui
toutes les composantes politiques et
sociales de la société française
les quartiers chics à ce n'est plus
déshérités une communauté qui a presque
doublé depuis l'arrivée des juifs
d'afrique du nord est où la part des
employés et des cadres moyens et de plus
en plus importante
une communauté où l'on peut être
religieux sans être forcément
pratiquants mais où l'on peut également
se sentir juif tout en étant athée et
sur les grands problèmes de société
peine de mort greffe humaine ou racisme
le sentiment religieux exclu rarement
l'apport de la réflexion personnelle je
crois qu il convient de maintenir le
principe de la peine de mort dans des
cas tout à fait exceptionnel lorsqu'il
s'agit de crimes particulièrement odieux
parce qu'il faut que la sanction soit à
la mesure du crédit mais ceci doit être
absolument exceptionnel et je dirais
même rarissime en ce qui concerne
l'exécution de la peine de mort là je
crois qu'il l'a il serait bon que tout
le cérémonial un peu théâtral et
sanglant qui entoure la peine de mort
soit supprimée alors sur la greffe
d'organes le judaïsme a pris position
officiellement par une déclaration
récente du rabbinat français la position
du déisme est la suivante le corps est
aussi divin que la et en ce qui concerne
la greffe d'organes nous sommes
extrêmement réservés et nous ne
l'admettons que s'il y a des chances
extrêmement sérieuse et immédiate de
sauvegarde d'une vie humaine
ce que vous appelez la nostalgie du
nazisme il ya un certain nombre de
manifestations d'un certain romantisme
un peu suspect avec tout le bric à brac
des uniformes des signes d armes nazis
et il faut absolument que l'on applique
la loi qui condamne aussi bien les
manifestations antisémites ou racistes
que l'apologie des crimes nazis
l'histoire des juifs de france est déjà
vieille de dix neuf siècles
ils doivent à la révolution de 1791 leur
citoyenneté française et le respect de
leurs traditions
on se marient souvent le dimanche les
israélites 50 mariage religieux célébré
aujourd'hui à paris il y actuellement en
france 650 mille personnes de confession
juive tentative de coup d'état ou
cambodge s'élargit la radio de phnom
penh qui vient de l'annoncer seulement
maintenant d'ailleurs alors que cela
s'est passé à la fin du mois de mai coup
d'état manqué les responsables sont des
vietnamiens aidé par la cia et 10 les
cambodgiens
ils ont été arrêtés le deuil a été
décrétée dans beaucoup de pays arabes
après l'attentât qui a coûté la vie hier
au président du nord-yémen lieutenant
colonel al gâche me il a été tué par une
valise piégée que transportait un
émissaire du sud du yémen
bien évidemment les relations
diplomatiques entre les deux pays ont
été immédiatement rompu
maurice werther nous rappelle maintenant
quels sont les traits essentiels de ces
deux pays le yémen héritier de
l'ancienne fédération d'arabie du sud
alors colonie britannique est divisé en
milliers même du nord capitale sanaa au
yémen du sud capitale aden le président
de la république du nord yémen
le lieutenant-colonel gâche me elle est
au pouvoir depuis octobre 77 seulement
il succédait au colonel
dit que nous voyons ici interrogé pour
antenne 2 il ya un peu plus d'un an à
sanaa par gérard ce bac et le colonel
hamdi lui aussi a été assassiné
aujourd'hui le sud-yémen dément
formellement avoir projeté et fait
exécuter l'assassinât du colonel gâche
me et accuse le site
ceux qui sont hostiles à la
réunification du yémen bien qu'il porte
le même nom les deux mêmes sont très
différents le yémen du sud est un état
socialiste très dur le nord s'était doté
d'un régime à peu près neutraliste à la
suite d'une longue guerre civile
mais un coup d'état en 1967 à renverser
les neutraliste est porté au pouvoir un
gouvernement très modérée politiquement
proche de l'arabie séoudite lui-même du
nord l'ancien arabie heureuse est en
réalité un pays très pauvres qui
dépendent dans une large mesure des
largesses de l'arabie séoudite l'arabie
après l'assassinât du président gâche me
a fait rapidement savoir qu'elle ne
tolérerait pas un changement de régime
au nord-yémen bien qu'on en parle de
temps à autres bien que les chefs
d'états du nord et aussi du sud
fast état de velléités de se rencontrer
la réunification des deux yémen selon
les régimes sont aux antipodes est
encore plus improbable que celle des
deux allemagne où des deux corées il est
vrai que l'exemple et 2 vietnam donne à
réfléchir
violence également pendant ce week-end
en rhodésie il ya eu près de 40 morts en
24 heures
un fermier blanc tué dans sa voiture au
cours d'une embuscade parmi ces 40 mans
et puis 12 missionnaires blancs
massacrés selon les autorités des soldes
bury par un commando partisans du
pouvoir noir en redit ce monsieur valdaï
le secrétaire général des nations unies
a appelé tous les parties concernées par
ce problème rhodésien à négocier il faut
bien avouer que ces tueries il n'ya pas
d'autre mot rendre encore plus difficile
la recherche d'un règlement politique
des images pénibles
les victimes de ce massacre sont des
missionnaires britanniques les
missionnaires sont souvent pris entre
deux feux venu pour convertir aux
pauvres des écoles comme c'est le cas
ici dans l'est de la rhodésie il leur
arrive de se ranger carrément du côté
des forces de l'ordre les rhodésiens
blanc ou franchement du côté des
guérilléros ce noir attitude qui les
désigne à la vindicte des uns et des
autres en rhodésie la situation
politique n'est pas simple le premier
ministre monsieur lien smith a conclu un
accord avec certains mouvements noirs de
tendance très modéré c'est à une
majorité de ce type que les blancs
doivent en principe céder le pouvoir le
1er janvier 1979
mais les noirs les plus radicaux le
front patriotique de monsieur mugabé ne
croit pas à la sincérité de monsieur
smith et mène depuis 6 ans un combat de
guerrila dont le massacre de vendredi
est un des plus affreux épisode
les français en majorité sont favorables
à l'élection de l'assemblée européenne
au suffrage universel c'est le résultat
d'un sondage sofres publié par
l'hebdomadaire valeurs actuelles
il était réalisé ce sondage entre le 2
et le 6 juin 78 sur un échantillon
national de 1000 personnes
pourtant reconnaît valeurs actuelles à
un an des élections l'idée européenne
reste faiblement mobilisatrice et puis
dans une interview publiée par un
journal espagnol valéry giscard
d'estaing a affirmé que la compréhension
mutuelle entre le roi juan carlos et lui
même étaient utiles pour développer et
renforcer les relations franco
espagnoles
la contribution de l'espagne
démocratique est essentielle pour le
progrès de l'europe a également déclaré
le chef de l'état
georges leclercq je vous ai demandé de
venir ce soir dans le journal parce que
il ya au moins trois informations qui
ont attiré mon attention
aujourd'hui d'abord il ya une
installation par tdf télédiffusion de
france d'un premier émetteur de
télévision alimenté par l'énergie
solaire
oui alors c'est une très bonne nouvelle
pleine de promesses pour les parties en
énergie solaire ça prouve que l'énergie
solaire par photopiles non seulement et
déjà rentable mais en plus c'est
meilleur que les autres dans les
endroits isolés où sont les réémetteurs
alors je vais quand même vous rappeler
qu'à encore mieux ce sont les
associations entre les photopiles
l'éolienne de photopiles pour la journée
l'éolienne pour le vent la nuit toutes
les deux formes d'énergie solaire pour
le public les photopiles sont encore un
peu disons marginale elle pourrait
servir à alimenter des des antivols sur
les maisons mais je vous rappelle quand
même que l'énergie solaire est essentiel
maintenant par exemple dans les chauffe
eau solaires qui sont déjà en vente ou
les maisons solaires que vous pouvez
acheter dès demain les pères deuxième
information il y a eu une fuite dans une
centrale nucléaire en belgique à tihange
oui alors 8 qui n'est pas colmatée
encore là ce que je voudrais dire c'est
que encore une fois ce qu'il faut
déplorer c'est le manque d'information
c'est une association d'écologistes et
hamida terre qu'il a annoncé la première
ce n'est qu'après que la confirmation
est venue le porte parole de la centrale
a aujourd'hui déclaré que la fuite dont
ce n'est pas colmatée qu'ils avaient
fait appel sont des belges à une équipe
française de spécialistes est qu un des
techniciens a eu un malaise mais pas du
tout radioactif s'était plutôt un
malaise nerveux car la troisième
information c'est plutôt un dossier qui
sera d'ailleurs ouvert
dix prochains sur antenne 2 les dossiers
de l'écran concernés consacrée plutôt à
la pollution des mers
et puis il ya cette enquête réalisée par
l'express sos méditerranée oui alors
c'est une réunion qui était donc à hier
où le
le président margaillan a dit qu'il
fallait 100 milliards de centimes pour
sauver la méditerranée il y a tout
autour de la méditerranée énormément du
sinn énormément d'installation de ville
il ya plus de 100 millions de personnes
qui vivent en permanence autour de la
méditerranée est beaucoup plus bien sûr
en étaient toutes ses usines créer des
pollutions la méditerranée finalement
lesquin lac dans les ondes se renouvelle
que lentement 80 85 ans environ donc
toutes les pollutions du mal à être
digérée par la mer ce qu'il faut ce
n'est pas simplement collecter les eaux
usées mais épuré ses eaux usées c'est le
cri d'alarmé qu'a lancé bon bah il a dit
donc qu'il fallait un milliard de francs
pour sauver la méditerranée je vais vous
dire en conclusion gérard je suis allé à
une telle réunion en 1972 à beyrouth
pour sauver la méditerranée on y disait
exactement la même chose et rien n'a
changé et rien n'a changé merci georges
leclercq très rapidement parce qu'il ya
finale de la coupe du monde qui nous
attend et ces deux-là mondiovision ne
perdons pas de temps je vous rappelle
rapidement les résultats du tiercé de 17
et 9 n'est pas encore les rapports de ce
tiercé pierre-alain dans le dernier
journal devrait les avoir tout à fait en
fin de soirée
je vous rappelle également la sortie
d'un de nos confrères de nos prochains
confrères c'est un mensuel il s'appelle
album un peu sophistiqué mais des
articles assez intelligent et puis la
météo pour demain également rapidement
demain le temps sera nuageux et frais
avec encore quelques averses suivi
d'éclaircies sur les régions
septentrionales
il y aura des températures en faible
hausse mais qui resteront inférieures
aux variables saisonnières voilà en
relisant donc que c'est pierre-alain qui
vous présentera la dernière édition du
journal j'aurais mis un point final à
celui ci je vous souhaite une très belle
soirée et une bonne finale de coupe du
monde